Good morning.
For two or three of you out
there who don't know me,
I'm Bill Hecht class of '61.
And I'm your senior employee as
head of the Alumni Association.
[APPLAUSE]
You might wonder how a
guy from the class of '61
got a red coat.
A number of years
ago the class of '24,
which is celebrating
its 70th this year,
had some issues that
needed settling.
And somehow or other I was able
to settle them for that class.
And as a great
privilege and tribute
they made me an honorary
member of that class,
insisting that I always
wear a freshman tie.
So I now have my own two
connections, a six and a one.
My graduate degree was in '76
and my undergraduate in '61.
And '24 which I'm
just as proud of.
And I'm busting
my buttons to say
that in '95 my daughter will
get a master's from this place,
so I'll have another
MIT connection.
I wonder if you all know that
last night's pops was not only
a very special night for
us, but it was actually
a test for the potential
new conductor of the pops.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
It is said that he practiced
Arthur Fiedler's hand motions
studiously before the mirror.
And I think that
I'm going to take
on the job of being his
agent and represent him,
because I think we can get
a hell of a good contract.
Finally, it's my great
pleasure in addition
to welcoming you all here
today to introduce Chuck Vest.
Chuck is president
of MIT as you know.
He came to us about
four years ago.
And he may be a
little wistful today.
As you know, many
people who come
in the fall of four years ago
graduated about a week ago.
His class, the class
of '94 did leave.
Chuck, I guess fortunately
for us, but perhaps not so
fortunately for him,
still remains with us.
So let me introduce Chuck
Vest, president of MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much, Bill.
I'm just signed up for
the new five-year master
of engineering program.
That's all.
I've been for years
wanting to get up the nerve
to ask Bill exactly
what this great favor he
did for that class is.
But because I'm not
sure of its legality
I've been afraid to ask.
[LAUGHTER]
On a more serious note,
and a very happy one,
I understand that we
have a record number
of alums and families here for
reunions on Technology Day.
You are over 3,000 strong.
My congratulations.
And we all have an
exciting day ahead of us.
[APPLAUSE]
The speakers for today's
program are truly
a stellar group
of men and women,
who will talk about art
and culture in the Academy,
and specifically at MIT.
Here at MIT, where the arts have
evolved over a hundred years
from a single extracurricular
activity in 1884,
the MIT Banjo Club, to a
panoply of artistic and cultural
endeavors that you're going to
have a chance to sample here
today in 1994.
Special thanks go
to Jorge Rodriguez,
chairman of the
Technology Day Committee.
And to all the members of
the Technology Day Committee,
the Council for the
Arts, for putting
together such an astounding
and exciting program.
I might add that the
watercolors reproduced
in the Technology Day
poster was painted
by one of our graduate students
in the School of Architecture
and Planning, Lian Quan
Zhen, and that there
are other examples of his work
on display today in the lobby.
Now to some it might seem odd
that in this bastion of science
and engineering we bring
together our alumni and alumni
to celebrate the arts.
But most of you probably had
at least a brush with the arts
at MIT, and many of you I'm
sure became more deeply involved
in our music and
theater arts programs.
And now more than ever, our
students and our faculty
are engaged in a wide range of
artistic and cultural pursuits.
In the visual arts, and
architecture, music, theater,
creative writing
and photography.
As well as in the emerging
media of interactive video,
holography, and
hyperinstruments.
Still, some of
you might ask why.
While it is true that
MIT is best known
throughout the world for
the caliber of the engineers
and scientists we send
out from this place,
the Institute has in fact
produced a steady flow
of artists, architects,
musicians, dancers, actors,
and others who are best known
for their artistic endeavors.
We have string players and
wind players, composers
and conductors in orchestras
around the country.
We have actors on
Broadway and in Hollywood.
And we have MIT graduates on
the faculties of music schools
and many other universities.
Of course, most MIT
students continue
to pursue traditional careers
in engineering and science.
But we are no less serious
about teaching music, theater,
and the arts to these students.
The arts, when taught
seriously and deeply,
offer our students opportunities
to expand their imagination,
broaden their
perspective, and imagine
ever-widening new possibilities.
This is true for all of us.
When we develop our ability
to think creatively,
we were able to
find new solutions
to the problems on
which we are working,
both in our laboratories and
in other aspects of our lives.
Take for example the
fields of engineering,
and particularly
engineering education.
We are moving very dramatically
toward a more integrative style
of education, with
increased emphasis on design
and synthesis, and a little
bit less emphasis on analysis
and reduction in science.
I think that art,
and an appreciation
for the aesthetic components
of all that people do
is very helpful in this regard.
As we work to improve
the quality of designs
and products, it's
going to be increasingly
important for engineers
to co-operate with artists
to tackle the visual, tactile,
and aesthetic qualities
of their work.
But quite aside from their role
in scientific and engineering
endeavors, the arts
should of course still
be an important part of our
lives and of our education.
Why?
Because they are
part of our humanity.
They reflect our
human experience.
The arts give us
a different kind
of connection with
the world, and they
can help us to understand the
many cultures that make up
our community and our world.
The arts allow people from
very different perspectives
and backgrounds to
communicate, and to interact
with an almost build-in
degree of mutual respect.
This is important
for our graduates
as they take their skills into
an increasingly interdependent,
global, and multicultural world.
And this is very
important for MIT.
The more innovative we are in
celebrating and encouraging
the richness and diversity
of our community,
the better off
all of us will be.
In some, the arts at MIT
are essential elements
of our education and
of our community life.
Not only are they healthy
here, they are thriving.
This is great testimony to
the talent, the dedication,
and the enthusiasm of a great
many faculty and students.
And it is particular
testimony to one person
who has done an extraordinary
job in stimulating
and supporting the arts
since she arrived here
at MIT in 1989.
I refer, of course, to my
colleague Professor Ellen
Harris, associate provost
for the arts at MIT.
Ellen is a distinguished
scholar of music,
who is also known widely
as a soprano soloist.
She came to us from the
University of Chicago,
where she was a professor
of music and head
of the Department of Music.
As a scholar, she has been
recognized for her work
on the music of Handel.
As a singer, she is best
known for her dramatic stage
performances.
Those of you who were here
for commencement last week
and heard her sing
the national anthem
know precisely what I mean.
Ellen's arrival on campus
was the final fulfillment
of a set of recommendations
made in 1987 by an arts review
committee, which recommended the
appointment of a senior officer
who would also be
a faculty member
in either the performing
or visual arts.
Someone to take
broad responsibility
as an advocate leader
and coordinator
for the creative arts
program here at MIT.
Believe me.
Ellen Harris serves
superbly in that role.
Ladies and gentlemen,
professor Ellen Harris.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Chuck.
Good morning.
Oh, good.
It's often been said that at MIT
one's education is like taking
a drink from a firehose.
What I have noticed is
that so is Tech Day.
We have you here before 9:00
in the morning after having you
out very late last
night, and I appreciate
seeing you all here so
bright and raring to go.
I'm proud and privileged
to welcome you
to The Wonder of It All,
the Arts at MIT Technology
Day 1994.
And I want to add my
thanks to Jorge Rodriguez,
the chair of the alumni
Tech Day committee.
And also to Eliza Dame,
who does so much, more
than I can possibly say, to make
Tech Day work year after year.
Many people like to talk
about the arts at MIT
as if it's an anomaly,
as if it's a surprise,
or as if it's something new.
But of course you know
better than anyone else
that that is not the case.
The arts have been a part
of MIT since its founding.
MIT was the first school
to establish a school
of architecture in 1868.
It actually began offering
courses in architecture
in its first year, 1865.
In that same year we
were offering courses
in photography and in drawing.
In 1884 we not only
established the Banjo Club,
but we established
the Glee Club.
In 1928 we established
Drama Shop,
the forerunner of our
theater curriculum today.
And in 1948 John
Corley came to MIT
to establish the MIT band, an
organization that he continues
to conduct today.
[APPLAUSE]
In 1950 the Hayden
Gallery opened,
which was the forerunner of our
now internationally renowned
List Visual Arts Center.
But perhaps most
importantly, in 1944--
50 years ago today--
MIT first established its
eight-semester sequence
in humanities.
Those of you who have been
at the Institute since 1944
will remember your eight
courses in the humanities.
They used to be different
than they are today.
But in 1944 they included
I think a first-year course
in writing and
English literature,
second-year course in history,
third-year course where
you could choose from
a number of subjects,
including economics.
And in the fourth year a
wider selection of courses,
including a yearlong
course in music.
Because of this
eight-semester sequence
of courses, which parallels
the eight-semester courses
in science, MIT has had for many
years a program in education
which has been referred
to here as dual literacy.
MIT students have been
asked to be literate
not only in science, but in
humanities and in the arts.
In fact, MIT may be one of the
few educational institutions
in the country that asks
this of its students.
It is very, very easy
at many liberal arts
institutions to
avoid the sciences.
Not so easy at MIT to
avoid the humanities.
In fact, this dual
literacy has meant
that we have within
our students and alums
many people who have gone
on to careers in the arts.
In fact, in the class of 1994,
I can think of four cases
immediately.
Two young men who
have double majored
in mathematics and
music, both of whom
are going on right now
to graduate school.
One to the University of
Chicago, and one to Duke
in music composition.
We have another
student who majored
in civil engineering
who has received
a full scholarship to pursue
writing at Boston University.
And we have another student
who majored in theater
at MIT, who is going on to
pursue his work in theater, who
hopes to establish
his own theater
company in the
countryside of Mexico.
I sometimes think
we must graduate
the most scientifically
literate artists in the world.
But this is not something
that was just true
of the class of 1994, and I was
looking at the reunion classes
for some other examples.
And obviously, we have
a lot of people today
here from the class of 1944.
Right?
[APPLAUSE]
Well, one of your
members, John Bavicchi,
who graduated with a
major in management,
has gone on to be a
very well-known composer
and conductor, who has
been for many years
on the faculty of the
Berklee School of Music.
From the class of '64--
'64?
Do I hear the class of '64?--
we have John Miller
who double majored
in humanities and
engineering, who
has made his career as
principal bassoonist
with the Minnesota Orchestra.
Class of '69.
[APPLAUSE]
You had with you for
some time James Woods,
who was majoring in
political science
before he went on to become
a very well-known actor.
In '79--
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
I think we need
more energy folks.
Liz Maruska, who went on to
become a practicing artist
on the West Coast, who
paints beautiful canvases
in watercolor and gouache
expressing time and space.
And finally, class
of '89, five years.
[APPLAUSE]
Ken Goodson, who majored in
both mechanical engineering
and music, received
his master of science
in '91 in mechanical
engineering, his PhD in '93,
is now studying and
performing as a baritone
soloist in Germany.
I love, about Ken, that when
he performed at Tanglewood
as an MIT grad, it is
only appropriate that when
singing in Stravinsky's
work, "The Flood,"
Ken Goodson play
the role of God.
[LAUGHTER]
But obviously MIT does not
graduate all of its students
to go on in the arts.
You don't need to be
an arts professional
to benefit from the arts.
And whether you worked in Doc
Edgerton's strobe photography
lab, or perhaps
became interested
in physics through
Bernice Abbott's
extraordinary photographs
of physical phenomena that
were published in many
high school textbooks
and that were taking
at MIT, or whether you
played in the symphony,
or sang in the Glee Club,
or acted in a
theatrical production,
I am sure that at some point
art touched your life at MIT,
and has continued to touch
your life thereafter.
Arts offer us discipline.
Anyone who has practiced
the piano knows that.
Arts offer us imagination.
They offer us the
flexibility of a pursuit
where there is not
one right answer.
But they also offer us
new ways of organization--
of organization of sound,
and space, and time.
The arts offer us a doorway into
cultures other than our own,
that enables us not only
to tolerate but respect
difference.
The arts challenge
us, surprise us.
Sometimes they anger us.
But the arts also bring
us wonder and joy.
And today we hope to explore,
through our presentations,
the wonder and joy of
the arts today at MIT.
This of course,
leads me directly
to our first speaker, Philip
Morrison, Institute Professor
emeritus at MIT.
You are probably
familiar with his work
in astrophysics and cosmology.
Maybe less familiar with
his work as a filmmaker.
I first came to know
Philip through a copy
of a keynote
address that he gave
in 1986 for the 15th anniversary
of the Council for the Arts
at MIT, an organization
founded in 1971
to advise and support MIT in the
expansion of its arts programs.
At that time he
said, and I quote,
"It's clear that if an
institution like this one which
deals with the material world
did not have the side of art,
it would be a self-defeating
proposition which in the end
would be all genetic seed
and no fruit to the apple.
And an apple is
not made that way."
I think that I can do no
better in introducing Professor
Morrison than to quote his
colleague Victor Weisskopf who
said of him, "Scientific
knowledge and understanding is
not a purely cerebral affair.
It is soaked with
emotion, excitement,
and nervous tension,
as everybody
knows who has ever heard
Professor Morrison speak."
Ladies and gentlemen,
please help me
to welcome Professor Morrison.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
Much equipment here.
All of it seems to work.
I'm especially impressed by
the video projection system.
The Wonder of it All
at MIT: The Arts at MIT
is a very nice title.
Doesn't say much.
Commits very few speakers.
I would certainly like to
affix firmly onto the word
"wonder," because clearly
that's the kind of motive which
lies behind nearly all the
things that go on at MIT,
translated as
eventually they are
into the hard tasks
of earning a living
and making this world work.
The old classical
Chinese scholars
always like to pretend that the
ideas they had were very old.
So they found some
mysterious figure
of the past who nobody
knew much about, typically
the Yellow Emperor.
And they said, well, the Yellow
Emperor first said, and then
they made up their own books.
[LAUGHTER]
We don't do that now.
We have a much more
forward-looking--
we don't look back in general.
It's always new.
That's the same
error in reverse.
People have this tendency
for bipolar positioning,
bipolar stability of large axis.
Because everything is both--
has something old,
has something new,
or it's not being
pursued very far.
That's the typical lesson.
Ask a historian, he'll
take it back for you.
Ask a projector of the
future, he'll push it forward.
Both things lie in time.
I wondered however, and I
didn't always know this,
and I became more and
more convinced of it
in the past recent
times, few years maybe,
the proposition that this
issue that we now debate
is extraordinarily old.
I could invoke no
newer phrase for it
than this Latin tag of the
Institute, mens et manus, mind
and hand, to talk about it.
Because of course, that
is the exquisite pleasure
of the MIT ambience--
that minds and hands are
equally well-occupied.
That means to say that a
lot of mechanical things
are done-- a lot of things
in the material world,
or with the refractory
symbols of the world,
they're hammered away
at, whether it be metal,
or melodies, or whatever it is.
But it's not done by
and large by rote.
Obviously some rote goes
into all operations.
Experts become routinized.
But thought is at the basis.
And it turns out that
that unity, which
is a profound unity between
art and the triune quality
of modifying and knowing
the world physically, craft,
engineering, and science
in their relationships
goes back a very long time.
And I brought along a few
slides to justify that
and to get us well started.
So it's not a new task
that we're looking into.
This wonderful picture in the
center, collection of rocks,
deserves some close attention.
Those rocks are
not natural rocks.
The fact that they are
quite similar I think
is pretty evident.
It's also quite evident--
if you look more closely,
not easy to see perhaps,
it's better to handle them.
We can't do that, but I think
it's enough to suggest it
in a context like this.
You can see the three edges
here, the double ones there.
Every one has faceted edges.
This one has in fact a
slight double, a kind
of blade-like edge and so on.
This is a pile of rocks--
a section, a collection--
made by the excavators
in Olduvai Gorge in the
rift of East Africa.
These were not found that way.
They were found stratum after
stratum, carefully located,
carefully arranged in position
so they could be dated.
But the photographer simply
gathered a lot of them
to give us an
impression of how many
hundreds, indeed many thousands,
of these stone tools are found.
Now, the remarkable part
about them-- this of course
is mens et manus.
Mens is pretty thin still.
These are not even
our own species.
These are our distant forebears.
They were poor.
They first walked the earth
fearful of the beasts.
Pretty soon that
stopped, and the beasts
tended to avoid them.
Before that perhaps
even they scavenged
on the kill of the lion.
But sooner or later, this kind
of operation symbolized here--
mind and hand-- began to
change where they were.
And they did marvelous things
on a very slow time scale.
The pieces represented
in this collection,
just that arbitrary piece
of a large collection,
are measured not by centuries,
but by thousands of centuries.
Yes.
By hundreds of
thousands of years.
A few 100,000 years corresponds
to a typical collection
at Olduvai, which might extend
to a million years or more.
But to be generous we'll say
a few thousand centuries.
Now the striking part of
this is that these tools,
without very much
change, are found
over a very large
part of the world
as the next slide will show.
There it is.
Here are famous sites.
Anyone who has read anything
about early archeology
will recognize these
kinds of locations.
From Britain up here,
into Europe, France,
at the Pyrenees.
Especially very
important in there.
All across Africa, East Africa.
Here we have Olduvai itself
and down to Cape Town.
So from Britain to Cape Town,
and from Cape Town across Asia,
Central Asia, India, North
China, Peking, further north
still and into Java.
All these-- the major sites.
Each site feathers out into
many, many little excavations.
And from all of these places
about the same kind of tools
are collected.
Yes, the experts argue a
bit, and they can somewhat
classify them.
But it's really quite
hard to date them
except by the attendant
pieces of mineral which
can enable you to date
them by radioactive means.
But you'll notice that
not one site is found
in these islands or Australia.
And I've left out the Americas.
No use to put it on the map.
Because not one
site of this kind
has ever surely been
found in America.
No.
Australia, the great
islands near Australia,
and the two Americas do not
belong to these people, who
I don't wish to say are--
they are our ancestors.
Cannot speak ill of them.
They were in fact
the Prometheans.
Because somewhere in
the middle of their span
Homo erectus figured out how
to make and control fire.
And the hammer at
MIT is entirely
secondary to the
fire, and all that
goes with that symbolically.
So I don't show you those
sites, though of course there
are very many sites in America.
But none of them show
the bones or the tools
of these ancient folk.
We truly, like the Australians--
the Australian Aboriginals,
the Native Americans--
are the modern humans,
like all the rest of
this place has also been
filled in by modern humans.
I don't mean to say we're--
of course we're not.
Most modern humans live
in this part of the world.
But the same species
occupies this whole region.
And only after a long time,
after thousands of centuries,
it managed, they managed, in the
course of some internal change,
which is what we would
call a change in species
to Homo sapiens, they managed--
by means that can be well
debated and interesting
to study--
they managed to be able
to cross the then much
shallower coastal seas,
and finally the great Gulf
of the Timor Trench.
And come somehow by canoe
or raft to Australia,
and in the same way go
across the relenting Arctic
where the glaciers were
melting, and follow
the coast line of America.
And go down the full length of
both continents rather quickly,
and that completed the
occupation of the world
by modern humans.
So we are the new world.
Not because of
Columbus or any feature
of historical importance.
Those are small matters.
The real thing was
we we were new,
because the new people who
filled up the old lands very
well had a way also
to get to new lands
never before occupied.
So our histories go back only
a few hundred centuries, not
a few thousand centuries.
There's an order of
magnitude difference
between the kind of thing you
saw in the Olduvai rocks--
bifaces, choppers, hand
axes they're called,
and the kind of thing that
came when a new set of persons
of whom we are all
descended, we can prove
by the deepest of
biological means
how united the whole world
is in our single species,
with subspecies as we well know.
And the next slide
will show what
you find in these new sites.
Now please compare these,
which are nice American pieces.
They were made about
12,000 or 14,000 years ago.
These are found in
a region in Montana.
And of course they're
specialized for killing
big game.
And if you'd like to know
what the big game was--
probably you do know--
it was elephants.
Pieces quite like this,
spear points like this,
have been found in contact with
the bones of bison and mammoth.
And of course, where the
other rocks had 10 or 20
rather cunning blows struck
which you and I could not do,
which people can train
themselves to do today,
these have many hundreds
of knowing strokes
to chip the blade
just correctly.
And even along the
edge you can see
to sharpen it with a wonderful
thing, very detailed marks
up there, all of which are
significant in producing
a handy and useful blade.
So I have no doubt to say this
is craftsmanship, possibly even
engineering.
At least its high-quality
craftsmanship,
because we know now that many
of these blades have to be heat
treated in order to allow
the chert and the flint
to respond to the chipping.
But now I'd like to go a little
farther and show what they did.
And it happens that the
preservations I have now
are again the same new
people, our people,
but now coming
from France and not
from Montana, the following.
A bone object used
for working sinew
and straightening arrow shafts.
You can see the hole there.
But it wasn't enough
to make it utilitarian.
It has this marvelous
leaping horse
worked into the same material.
And this was about 200 or 250
centuries old from Bruniquel,
a cave in France.
We have art so much
from France and Spain
because the caverns are
so well-protected there.
They guarded the art
behind stalactites
for many thousands of years.
And the next slide,
perhaps even more
striking, an image itself,
an elk of the period.
The biologist will find
fossils that fit it quite well.
Beautifully drawn in
charcoal and ocher
on the wall of the French cave.
This was the famous
cave of Lascaux.
So I rest the case that
the relationship that
changed, that came
to human beings,
we don't exactly
know what it is.
Most likely it was
the acquisition
of a powerful
language, which enabled
them to work cooperatively
and to model the future,
gave rise to the
craft and the art,
which you unmistakably
see here, which goes back
not merely thousands of years,
but tens of thousands of years.
This particular piece is dated
about 15,000 or 18,000 years
ago, the previous one
about 20,000 years ago.
And all from that
same flood of persons
who occupy the
world, maybe in all
not more than half a
million of them by the time
the Americas were settled.
And we've grown them from that
half million to half trillion,
a very large number of
powers of 10 in population.
Thank you.
Now the linkage
between the craft--
engineering, science,
art-- between hand and mind
expressed in this
way, I maintain
this is demonstrably old.
Indeed, we can see it even
in the beginnings of science,
the time of the Enlightenment
of the late Renaissance,
you couldn't buy
a microscope that
wasn't worked up and chased
and engraved to bear some art.
Partly that was style.
I'm not denying it.
Partly that was royal patronage.
I'm not denying that either.
Nevertheless, the work of
the hand was to be admired.
And it was rare to have
such skilled craftsmanship
in these new materials
with a new purpose.
And to some extent, we've
lost that feeling because
of a utilitarian quality,
and the already great expense
of making the complex
instruments which
now replace the sledgehammer
of the MIT seal.
Or augment the sledgehammer.
I don't want to run
down the sledgehammer.
Still a very
indispensable instrument.
What I would like to
emphasize, though,
is that this connection
is a profound connection.
And I'd like to describe a
little bit why I think it's so,
and why it parts the
hand-mind relationship
from a more symbolic one, which
is not absent from either.
Any of you who have
tried to learn a craft,
or a skill, or above
all an art, knows
how very close the reaction
of the hand and the mind
must be to make anything
work the way you choose.
And if you don't do that,
another draft has to be made.
Now of course those
who deal in symbols
alone have some of
the same quality,
but the hand is
much less present.
The symbols are, by
nature, more conventional.
What is characteristic of
art and science engineering
together is they represent--
almost always they're
presented to us,
and they need to be presented
to us in concrete form.
In single concrete examples.
Perhaps something more
than the poet Blake
called "minute
particulars," which
he felt all art and
science were compacted.
But certainly not generalities.
Generalities edged towards
philosophical description.
True, there's a big
domain in-between.
There are theorems
and propositions
that are indispensable,
that come out of thought,
and which govern many
of the things we do.
But I think it's fair to
say that works of art,
and the data of science,
and works of the engineer,
are all concrete examples.
And if you don't have those, you
have a very dry subject indeed,
that consists of
nothing of theorems,
about mechanics without notions,
or diagrams, or examples,
or particulars, which I suffered
through as a graduate student
once long ago at
another university
when I was studying mechanics.
We couldn't ask
questions, and we also
couldn't understand
the propositions.
We sure could learn
the words quite well.
Now there are
differences, of course.
I think that the principal
characteristic of art,
which I admit it is
somewhat rapidly losing,
but hasn't lost yet-- it can
be seen in almost all parts
of it--
its products, its
particulars, are
perceptual to the human being.
It's very hard to imagine
art translated through--
it's not impossible,
we see it today--
translated through some
intermediate device,
which turns it into
printouts and numbers.
Then you have to regraph it.
This is hardly art.
The immediacy is gone.
Though of course, a great
deal of the world of science,
great deal of the
data of science,
go beyond human perception,
involve intermediation
by instrumentation
of complicated kinds.
And auxiliary calculations
to bring together
the reading of the instruments
or program inside the computer,
which is doing the same thing.
And by and large, that's
the biggest distinction
I can see on the side
of how the work is done.
It is also true that
they are united in this.
Niels Bohr defined
science not only as effort
to order the world, which
surely it is, but there it
does not deal--
it does not differ
from philosophy,
or for that matter from poetry.
But it seeks to bring a
new experience, which again
is close to art, though
perhaps rather different
from the philosopher's work.
And if we talk
about engineering,
I think we have to say to bring
new means for the game you've
experienced this,
too, is necessary.
But all of this
definitional style
would very much connect
these two or three--
it's hard for me to
think of them as three,
but certainly a multiple
view of these matters.
I'd like to go still further
and talk about their internal--
the way it appears to
practitioners of it.
All of you as students
were practitioners.
All of you now are practitioners
in some direction or another.
And I think you will recognize,
feel sympathy with what I say,
when I say that there are
a couple of apparently
polar divisions, contradictions
opposites, which have to be
united in each of these things.
A curious but quite realistic
account of what people do.
For example, the passive
absorption of information
to learn a language, to learn
mathematical formulation,
to learn the use of
a pen or a brush,
to learn the language
of the stage, whatever
it might be-- to learn the
notes of the scale and the keys.
All of those things can be done
as a passive game where someone
feeds the information-- a
book, a program, a person--
and you gain it.
But of the other side, activity
is indispensable, especially
if to learn those things
with that beautiful word,
"productivity."
So it can again recombine
them for yourselves.
We know that the people
who teach physics at MIT
and everywhere else, that
the solving of problems--
onerous as it may be--
is a way to secure
the active knowledge
of the things
passively observed,
underlined in yellow
marker, the big propositions
in the textbook.
You've got to put them together.
You've got to make
them work for you.
You have to feel somewhat
what we say at home with them.
Until that's happened,
no genuine understanding
will come in.
The answering of multiple-choice
tests in familiar language,
choosing the right
one of six, is not
a very powerful
test for science,
for engineering, or for art.
It may be good
enough for learning
certain received
bodies of truth-- fine.
I'm not against it entirely.
But it is clearly-- in our day
it's a basis of controversy,
and surely overused.
So we have to combine the
passive and the active,
and activity is the sine qua
non of the hand and the mind.
The same similar dichotomy
goes between the analytic
and the synthetic.
It was said in popular
psychology only a few years
ago-- it was quite
popular in the magazines--
there were halves of the
brain, the left and the right.
And one attended to
the holistic things,
the organization, the concepts.
And one attended to the details,
the rigorous logical thinking.
One was suitable for
children, one for grown-ups,
and that was the general idea.
People who said that,
of course, were mostly
writers, because they
understood writing very well.
They knew how hard it was
to formulate good sentences
and paragraphs.
And they said, well,
in the kindergarten
they can draw quite
well and make images,
and that's enough for that.
Of course, this is a caricature.
It's a very bad proposition.
Analytic and synthetic
again are together.
The analyst indeed
may take things apart.
But the tools he uses were
themselves synthesized
by earlier designers
who synthesized
the scalpel, or the
method of least squares,
whatever it might be, by putting
together something new that
had not existed before.
So I reject that as a
harsh division of the world
and say, no.
Both halves of the
mind are necessary.
All parts of the
mind, like both hands.
And the unitarity
of this is visible,
and visible in the
sense that we all
know that for every geometrical
statement in Euclid,
an algebraic equivalent
can be formed.
And vice versa.
The symbols of language the
symbols of x and y and plus,
are no more foreign than
the lines and the angles.
They're just different
ways of presentation,
and they have a one
for one correspondence.
Of course, the
symbolism of our world
is so powerful now it extends.
It goes beyond what
we can easily draw.
You can do any dimensionality.
I accept that and use it daily.
But this is the issue.
Now there is a feeling that
there's a difference in tone,
and there is some difference.
The scientists and
engineers seem serious.
They're concerned with matters
of prosperity and penury.
Or sometimes life and death.
Or sometimes peace and war.
And this seems more
serious, perhaps,
than the more playful
activity of the artist.
But I recommend you, thinking
through our language,
the word "play" has
wide connotations.
The player may play
Medea, or Hamlet.
Hardly a lighthearted affair.
Something plumbing the
depths of human behavior.
Lightness of heart is
not the whole story.
The primary colors, and
the cube, the sphere,
are fine things for
the elementary school,
indispensable for
the small child.
But they are not the
whole story of play.
Play, which is unique
in the vertebrates,
and best developed in those
closest to us is profound.
I worked a lot
with Charles Ames,
who said that one of the most
serious activities in life
was play, and he demonstrated
it every day by what he did.
Play is a means of--
clearly what the word implies--
model making of the future.
What would it be to do like
that, not to carry it out,
not to make that
full investment?
But to acquire the mastery in a
more benign, a more acceptable,
a more easily
entered environment.
And that is what play is.
And since you cannot master
the world in a stroke,
play is an indispensable
feature of human behavior.
From word play of the infant
and the mother in the home,
to the most profound
thought of an Einstein
or a composer of great value,
Bach in the course of his work,
as any exposure to
art demonstrates
that these things have.
And the scientists,
too, must have it.
I'd like to say a word for
playful engineering, which
I think is an important
issue of our time
that we have not
yet fully engaged.
It's not new.
There always has
been such a thing,
but I'd like to show an
example of it in a slide.
I hope you can
recognize this slide.
It's a very unusual slide.
It was made in 1936.
It shows one of the greatest
works of playful engineering,
the Eiffel Tower.
You can perhaps recognize the
Avenue Chaillot down here,
and the arches of the Eiffel
Tower there, all heavily
illuminated in this time
exposure from 1936, where
of course, what you see is a
pyrotechnic display, fireworks,
off all parts of
the Eiffel Tower.
But of course, the Eiffel
Tower was built strictly
as a playful operation,
a decoration for Paris
from the 1889 World's Fair there
by a great structural engineer.
It worked 10,000 tons of
wrought iron, not of steel,
of wrought iron and rivets.
And made playfully.
Of course, managing
to extract a fee
from the people who come
so it can keep going,
keep itself painted.
And indeed, pay the shareholders
quite a considerable income,
I understand, over the years.
But nevertheless,
that's its foundation.
It doesn't do anything but
stand there magnificently.
At first, of course, attacked
by half the artists and writers
in Paris.
And now inseparable from
the nature of the city.
And I'm sure that you could
not possibly tear it down
without a major
revolution swirling
about the base of the tower.
Now playful engineering is not
enough practiced in our time.
It is practiced some.
We all know about it.
We know about it in sports
where it's become a specialty,
and almost lost its playful call
because of its heavy rewards.
And at MIT, from the impromptu
and very light-hearted hack,
of which I need not
give you any examples,
through the pedal-driven
aircraft of great renown,
to the wonderful
stroboscopic work
of Papa Flash, the
late Doc Edgerton.
To the sophisticated work,
whose 25th anniversary
is being celebrated
tomorrow at the
of Center of Advanced
Visual Studies, which
I remember for sort of three
or four works of grand works.
Not single works,
but whole campaigns
of playful engineering.
Mechanisms of extraordinary
wit and pleasure.
The use of aerial
photography as an art form,
not as a geodetic study or
a way of measuring crops.
And sky art, lasers and balloons
on grand scale just beginning
in this world in
the last few years.
And I am quite sure also
that the Palais du Louvre
has been recently subjected to
something which is architecture
and playful in its qualities,
and at the same time profoundly
purposeful.
And I'm sure that IM Pei and
Dean Mitchell will describe
something about that in
their talk of recent work
just to come.
Now I'm going to close.
And I want to close with a
somewhat novel end, which
I had not really planned,
but it was forced out of me
as I went through these
thoughts in the last few weeks.
I see one danger.
The danger is an
extraordinarily clear one,
and I think we have found
the best way to avoid it.
I'll tell you what that is
and see if you agree with me.
Please think about it.
It's something novel.
It's something of great
importance to all of us.
And it needs
widespread attention.
And that is it's clear
that nowadays art produces
its own truths.
The artwork is not judged by its
comparison with another canon
necessarily.
Yes, it might be of the
School of Beaux-Arts.
It might not.
The schools are various.
The techniques are innumerable.
The subject matter,
the minute particulars
are as wide as can be.
And I think we should
accept that as the freedom
that the artist has.
Of course, he may
follow a strict form.
He may wish to do that.
Or he may break loose
into something quite new.
But in any case, there's
no other criterion,
no external one.
The scientists must--
the input is what counts.
The data must be
reliably presented.
The engineer, the
object must work
for the purpose of
which it was intended
or some purpose close to that.
But the artist, it is
the output that counts.
Does it work for the
purpose he intended it--
to amuse, to entertain, to
teach, whatever it might be?
It doesn't matter
how he got there.
He isn't responsible to show
you the data on which he worked.
And on the other
hand, this leads
to a great danger, of which
a very tiny example my wife,
Phyllis Morrison,
helped me produce
for the next last slide.
Well.
It's the Eiffel
Tower again, right?
In fact, it's the same--
you'll see it's the same
pyrotechnic picture.
But spontaneously, with the
matter of a few seconds,
Phyllis has managed to
give a kind of impression
that there is a colorful
pyrotechnic display coming
from the great tower.
And of course, you are
all well sophisticated
enough with images,
and with now markers,
to recognize that of
course it has nothing
to the Eiffel Tower at all.
What does it have to do with?
It has to do with a
35-millimeter slide that
represented the Eiffel Tower
in 1936, which she has then
modified with just a very
small spontaneous artistic work
to make the point here.
But the image, however,
is itself, it is there.
And it means something.
It's actually quite striking.
And now the trouble
is we make images
so well today, we make so many,
we can make them so seamlessly.
We can change their
appearance in every way.
Not only visual images, but even
speaking more metaphorically,
auditory and the rest.
That there is a cut-off
between the world represented--
may not be represented.
But even those things when
they are represented, well
represented the image are no
longer good maps of each other.
The artist's intervention
is so powerful
that he has ended that.
Now that is not new to us.
We all experience it
internally, and it is probably
indispensable to the human mind
in the way we have evolved.
It is what we call
the world of dream.
In dream, visual
images are produced
which have maybe some
semblance of your experience.
Sometimes not, perhaps.
But when they have
semblance, we know very well
that those dreams are not the
relatively close approximations
to what is going on.
That the eyes which
are always limited,
and the video screen which is
equally and similarly limited,
bring to you approximations
of the real world.
Now what I am trying to say
is a danger that if we have,
as we do have, the
greatest 20th century
arts, the one that
attracts most people,
and I think has gradually,
gradually increased
its salience is the cinema.
And I strongly suspect
the 21st century
will make the video equivalent
of cinema with its music,
with its changes, which
is probable 3D nature.
And its motions and
change will probably
transcend all previous
visual experiences,
will make an enormous
push upon the world.
Whereas the capital
of this world
is only going to double
or triple and plateau out.
There isn't room for more.
There's not room in
the atmospheric balance
and the heat sources for more.
These sources of information
and image are enormous,
and they will continue.
And the real question
is that we not
be swamped in a dream world,
where we no longer pay
attention to what the
representation was
of, but only the nature of
the presentation itself.
That is, after all,
the artist's task.
And I cannot think of a better
way of understanding that
problem of conquering it than
by having people who know both
sides of the operation, who
have studied the arts to see how
much you can do to make
entertaining and wonderful
things that didn't exist,
but also how much you can do
to represent scrupulously
and meticulously the data
of the real world, the actual
performance of engineering
without hyperbole and public
relations and the rest.
To take only one
side or stay away
from the other,
that will not work,
because people are too clever
and they'll transcend it.
What is the best is
to expose them both.
Come right up front and
say, yes, this can be done,
the artist has one direction,
the engineer scientist
has another.
Both recognize their
enormous similarity,
but by their mutual
understanding
we can have a world which both
contains dreams, but is not
solely based on it.
And I think that's the only kind
of a world which is safe for us
to try to carry on the legacy
of the canyon at Olduvai.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]